failed former president Donald Trump
posted an unhinged tirade to truth
social truth essential because the
Republican National Committee had I
guess the audacity to make some
decisions about primary debates without
checking with Donald Trump first this is
so damn funny New York Times reported a
couple weeks ago what was it uh yeah two
weeks ago Fox News to host first
Republican presidential primary debate
all right no big deal the candidates
will face off in August in Milwaukee I
mean think of that the first debate is
only four months away of course the
Republican National Committee has to
make some decisions about that the
article says Republican National
Committee chairwoman Ronald McDaniel
says they will be asked to agree to a
loyalty pledge before they take the
stage this is something we've talked
about before Republican candidates will
be asked to sign a pledge that if they
lose they will support whoever is the
eventual nominee we've already dealt
with that in terms of whether Trump will
go for it so I won't delve into it again
um this is happening I mean it's a
completely unremarkable thing we're
going to host the very first debate with
Fox News it will be a Fox News
Republican primary debate said Ronald
McDaniel
um Trump who's the current front-runner
has refused to say whether he would
support a nominee other than himself in
a February radio appearance he said his
support would have to depend on who the
nominee was okay so it's like no big
deal the RNC is getting themselves set
up for some debates
Trump goes to Troth yesterday and says
quote I see that everybody is talking
about the Republican capital D debates
but nobody got my approval or the
approval of the Trump capital c campaign
before announcing them when you're
leading by seemingly insurmountable
numbers and you have hostile capital and
networks with angry Trump and Maga
hating anchors asking the quote
questions why subject yourself to being
libeld and abused also the capital S
second capital D debate is being held at
the Reagan Library the chairman of which
is amazingly Fred Ryan publisher of the
Washington Post no so Trump seems to be
saying he will not even participate in
the first Republican primary debate of
2024 and you know who thinks that this
is a logical thing to do
Trump propagandist Steve Bannon Steve
Bannon appeared yesterday on the Charlie
Kirk show and said it's all a joke we're
not having a primary basically
suggesting Trump should just essentially
be given the nomination I just noticed
there's something very strange going on
with my hair and I apologize for that
um here's Steve Bannon saying Trump
should just sit out the debates we don't
have a primary and we're not going to
have our primary when President Trump I
think is just the audacity to go the
Rankin Library run by the guy that that
is the Washington post's publisher
Frederick Ryan yep it's a
it's not a surprise the uh this is the
RNC
it's an insult to the president it's
insult to mag it's insult to all the
volunteers full stop no debates the only
piercing debates is is whoever the
Democrat nominee is that that's right
okay so let me interpret this for you
how dare anyone subject Trump to an
opportunity to embarrass himself which
could almost certainly only hurt him
rather than help him and to that extent
I actually get it I actually get it if
DeSantis doesn't run for let's imagine
DeSantis doesn't run if DeSantis doesn't
run
Trump is essentially a shoe-in he's
going to be up against ones and twos his
stock will probably rise dramatically in
the polling
the debate can only hurt him and then if
DeSantis does run there's a risk that
the debate could hurt him now again I've
said before I don't think that the
totally uncharismatic Ron DeSantis
is going to really be able to go against
Trump in a national campaign but could
he do okay in a single debate against
Trump maybe and it's certainly possible
that if DeSantis is running that it
would not be particularly good for Trump
in that debate but also if Trump was
prepared it could be good but it is seen
as a risk to Trump and how how dare
anyone have the audacity to actually
have a primary election Trump should
just be appointed the nominee is what
Trump and Charlie Kirk and Steve Bannon
seem to believe this is I wasn't kidding
when I said this is going to be a wild
and insane primary it's already that way
and four months from now I I know it's
like it's happening so quickly four
months from now when the debates start
it's going to be even more insane all of
these clips including Bannon on Kirk
will be on our Instagram which you can
find by searching for David Pacman show
on Instagram it'll be on Tick Tock it'll
be on Snapchat Facebook and of course
YouTube at youtube.com the davidpackman
show
one of our sponsors today is fume not
everything in a bad habit is wrong so
instead of a drastic uncomfortable
change why not just remove the bad part
from your habit fume is an Innovative
award-winning device that does exactly
that fume is not electronic there's no
Vapor or harmful chemicals fume is just
a delicious flavored air that makes
replacing your bad habit easy your fume
comes with an adjustable airflow dial
and is designed with movable Parts which
is great for fidgeting which can be
great for people breaking bad habits
look at what people online are saying
they weren't sure what to expect but
ended up loving the taste and the feel
stopping is something lots of people put
off because it's difficult to do but
switching to fume is easy and enjoyable
there's no reason that you can't be the
next fume success story head on over to
try fumed dot com and use the code
Pacman to save 10 percent when you get
the journey pack which comes with the
device and three flavors the link is
down below